you've earned this so hold it up high
you're gonna turn out of the battle of
the beers The Wall Street Journal
reporting that Modelo has overtaken Bud
Light as America's Top beer you may
think Modelo dethroned Bud Light after
this and Bud Light Sent Me possibly the
best gift ever a can with my face on it
led to this the Bud Light boycott
well that's partly true but it's not the
whole story it's also thanks to this guy
I had the privilege of being President
Obama's antitrust chief he filed a
lawsuit that changed everything for the
brand putting the imported Mexican beer
on the path to take down the king of
fears Bud Light this is the economics of
Modelo it's a world that changes all the
time but what's important never changes
but change came in 2012 when
Anheuser-Busch inbev looked to merge
with grubo Medela the Brewer of Modelo
Especial and Corona I started at the
justice department in early January of
2013 and the biggest first matter before
me was an investigation the staff had
into the effort by AB inbev to acquire
the worldwide rights to Modelo that year
ABN Bev maker of Bud Light along with
Miller Coors made up about 65 percent of
the U.S Beer Market what our
investigation found was that every year
inbev ABI and Miller Coors would raise
prices
Modelo kept their prices stable and
began to grow market share they were
competing on the merits and they were
winning and it appears that ab and Bev
didn't like that idea at all so the
government's Anti-Trust ERS advised the
world's biggest beer maker it
Modelo Especial before buying the
company we said you need inbev to
completely divest
any interest in Modelo as it relates to
the United States they thought I was
crazy and I said well I may be crazy
but if you don't agree that we're going
to sue and they hemmed it hard and so I
sued him after that AP and Bev agreed to
sell the U.S rights to Modelo Especial
that mostly sold wine and spirits but
also imported Modelo Especial to the U.S
we knew with them as an independent
owner of Modelo they'd have every
incentive to grow the brand maintain the
quality introduce new brand incentives
that inbev it just would not have had at
all Modelo and its new parent company
had a long way to go to Dethrone Bud
Light
so constellation began looking at its
marketing it starts with creating that
Universal broad appeal across all types
of consumers and then expanding our
investment and moving into English
language and telling that story to more
people they launched a new campaign
running ads like this the mark of a
fighter during live Multicultural
sporting events to reach new audiences
the fight clock is brought to you by
mobile
sales ticked upwards as more people
drank Modelo and that data was presented
to retailers using a constellation
program called Shopper first shelf we do
a lot of research behind the scenes we
lay out the optimal flow of the beer
aisle that will maximize retail sales
for the retailer which then also helps
our distributor partners and helps grow
the overall beer category they said
stores could increase sales by arranging
Modelo in a vertical line with Corona to
the left what's interesting is Modelo
despite as big a brand as it is the
brand awareness of Modelo is actually
much much lower than of Corona Extra the
idea was that consumers would see Corona
first and then intuitively look to the
right and find Modelo they also
recommended that Modelo be shelved in
the refrigerators since most imported
beer is purchased to be consumed within
six hours so Shoppers needed a cold
inside the refrigerators constellation
recommended it be placed at eye level
and near the door handle to maximize
visibility they found beers that moved
from hinge to handle position increased
sales by eight percent Modelo Especial
has enjoyed really high velocities for a
long time when we have really high
velocities what's important is that we
get enough space on the Shelf so that we
have enough inventory so the Shelf isn't
empty constellation pushed retailers for
more chefs space for Modelo because it
was selling so quickly sales Rose by the
end of the 2021 calendar year Modelo
Especial had passed AB inbev's Michelob
Ultra to land the number two spot by
retail store dollar sales that jump was
partially fueled by a push to shift
modelo's consumer base in the 2019
fiscal year modelo's consumers were
about 70 percent Hispanic and that
population has been growing helping to
drive sales but constellation was really
pushing to give the brand a mass Market
appeal it worked now about 45 percent of
modelo's consumer base is non-hispanic
both have driven more market share with
all of that growth analysts projected
that bud light was on track to lose its
top spot to Modelo as early as 2024 but
they probably didn't anticipate Bud
Light sales falling as dramatically as
they did Anheuser-Busch says Bud light's
U.S market share has saved and that it
will win back drinkers by staying away
from controversial topics since the
boycott the company has worked on New
Bud Light ads like this
emphasizing ties to football and country
music
a b and Bev also said let's not forget
millions of people still choose Bud
Light each day and year to date Bud
Light remains number one in volume sales
modelo's rise is really the result of
changing demographics changing consumer
tastes and Savvy marketing on the part
of constellation and then to sort of top
it all off this Bud Light boycott blew
it out of the water we expected we would
be in this position maybe a year or two
from now so it did happen a little bit
earlier than expected but it's a great
place to be but what we're focused on
now is how do we maintain this position
going forward now Modelo is on track to
have greater dollar sales for the full
year of 2023. so it looks to be
solidifying its place as the top beer in
America to give the American Consumer
choice is what competitive markets is
all about and up to the constellation
keep going they clearly have the
momentum and and the consumer Demand on
their side
foreign
[Music]